14 morts 28 voiliers encore manquant
c'est le terrible bilan provisoire de la
tempête dans la course du
FN le Norway resté au Havre les
syndicats bloquent toujours l'cluse et
la
situation plus de 10000 morts en Inde
après la rupture d'un barrage à l'ouest
du
pays mesdames et messieurs bonsoir
j'aurais aimé en ce 15 août fête de
Marie jour férier au combien n'avoir à
vous donner que des informations
agréablestendu mais l'actualité en a
décidé autrement ou plutôt la nature
c'est que depuis quelques temps la
nature se déchaîne notre petite planète
paraît en proid à une fièvre des plus
violentes qui prend les formes les plus
diverses il y a 15 jours c'était le
tremblement de terre aux États-Unis la
semaine dernière l'éruption de l'Etna
tous ces jours derniers le feu dans nos
forêts depuis 48h l'océan se déchaîne la
course à la voie l'Admiral SCAP a été
meurtrière je rappellerai d'un mot
qu'elle se compose de qure épreuves dans
celle du fnet en mer d'Irlande la Fenet
s'est couru 28 fois de depuis sa
création et l'on n'avait jamais eu à
déplorer de victime or cette fois-ci une
tempête que l'on n'attendait pas s levée
en mer d'Irlande la météo britannique
contrairement à ce qui a été affirmé a
indiqué dès lundi que la mer allait
devenir très grosse mais ce fut si
soudain que plus de 60 voaliers ont
chaviré et leurs équipages sont tombés à
l'eau malgré l'arrivée des secours les
plus divers le plus rapidement qu'il a
été possible on déplore 14 morts et l'on
craint que ce chiffre n'augmente car si
150 personnes ont été revêchées il est
encore impossible de dresser la liste de
celles qui l'ont pas été qui peut-être
ont été englouti HERV du nous apporte
des
précisions la météo anglaise s-elle oui
ou non trompée en tout cas cette photo
prise par le satellite météo sat montre
bien que le temps s'est dégradé en mer
d'Irlande à l'origine du drame un coup
de vent de force 10 et une mer déchaîné
il semble probable que les vagues soi
heuré à un courant contraire au large de
la côte de Corno entre le vent et le
courant leur hauteur a augmenté jusqu'à
atteindre 15 m et les défirlandes très
rapprochées les unes des autres ont
provoqué le retournement de nombreux
bateau depuis plus de 24 heures
plusieurs bâtiments de la Royale névi
auxquels sont venus se joindre des
bâtiments néerlandais et différents
chalutiers sillonnent la mer d'Irlande
ils sont aidés en cela par six avions et
CIN hélicoptères qui tentent eux aussi
de repérer les
naufragés malgré cette gigantesque
opération de sauvetage on est encore
sans nouvell de nombreux voiliers dont
certains sont peut-être coulé mais
peut-être aussi enfuite vers un abri
quelconque plusieurs jours seront
nécessaires pour établir le bilan exact
de cette tragédie mais chaque heure qui
passe amenuise les chances de retrouver
vivant ceux qui sont tombés à l'eau au
cours de la tempête à cette époque de
l'année la survie n'est en effet que de
quelques heures un espoir cependant une
météo plus clément qui devrait faciliter
la tâche des
sauveteur que ressenton lorsquon est un
naufragé qu'on attend des secours cela
va nous être dit par Pierre Fenfant
concurrent de la course en solitaire de
l'aurore cette épreuve empruntait ces
jours derniers un parcours qui se
situait légèrement au sud de celui de la
faceenet la mère y était encore grosse
pierre fonenfant a fait naufrage et a
été miraculeusement sauvé en pleine nuit
par un autre navigateur Olivier Moussi
il raconte son avent pass très très vite
je ça marche à fond
et je pense que j'étais pas mal placé le
bateau s'est cassé en tombant d'une
vague il a coulé en 10 minutes temps de
prévenir à la VHF de donner ma position
et puis de rassembler mes affaires
j'étais chercher le Canau de survie et
puis à ce momentl il s'est pas il s'est
pas ouvert j'ai essayé de tirer toutes
mes forces sur la corde mais rien à
faire les fusées il y en a à moitié qui
ont marché et les fumigènes par exemple
nont pas
marché à ce momentl bon il était trop
tard le bateau je mis pas j'avais pris
quand même bien mon temps parce que je
voulais abandonner le bateau dernier
moment mais ça a été très très vite je
me suis retrouvé à l'eau
avec avec rien avec un gilet et puis une
Bou couronne j'ai flotté j'ai flotté
pendant 10 minutes je pensais que
c'était foutu et puis j'ai trouvé une
lamp torche qui flottait par hasard à ce
moment-là ça m'a rordonné un peu
d'espoir et puis à ce momentl j'ai vu
Olivier arriver ça justement Olivier
aussi on parle beaucoup de ces canaux de
survie on dit que les normes de sécurité
ne sont pas vraiment respecté
aujourd'hui il y a véritablement un
problème avec ces canaux de
survie oui c'est c'est sûr un engin qui
vaut 8000 francs qui est obligatoire et
qui était neuf devrait absolument
sourvrir la faut on a besoin de
lui et surtout que par exemple j'avais
avant le départ un Cano qui était de
marque anglaise d'une marque extrêmement
fiable je crois que c'était enfin peu
importe et on ma obligé en acheter un
autre de marque française exactement la
même marque que celui de Pierre
d'ailleurs qui ne qui a fonctionné
COMC nous venons de recevoir les
premières images du désastre qui a
ravagé l'Inde la rupture du barrage de
morvy sur la côte ouest du pays là le
nombre des victimes est absolument
incalculable d'autant que les secours
nous vous le disions déjà hier soir ont
mis longtemps pour parvenir sur place
sur place cela veut dire dans la zone
des villages dévastés par l'eau du
barrage qui déferlait
minut c'est une ville entière et les 17
villages qui l'entourent qui ont été
rasés à la suite de la rupture du
barrage de
morvie aujourd'hui encore on ne sait
rien du nombre des
victimes selon un journal indien la
catastrophe aurait fait 25000
morts on parle en Inde de catastrophe
nationale 4 m de bout recouvre les
habitations un hôpital a été entièrement
détruit avec ses 200 malades et le
personnel médical les premiers
sauveteurs ont assisté aux scènes
atroces de l'exode de milliers de
survivants et déjà sur place on manque
de bois pour incinérer les morts il n'y
a plus d'eau
potable les conduites de gaz et les
circuits électriques sont
coupés l'acheminement des vivres de
l'eau et des médicaments se fait
difficilement un homme politique indien
a déclaré qu'une a éé dé dans le barrage
il a déjà longtemp mais que le
gouvernement n'avait alors rien fait une
enquête judiciaire
devraitop
40es au Avre le départ du norwayest
exacbo France a été retardé la nouvelle
a été annoncée à l'équipage par
haut-parleur de la passfale du PACBO la
décision du report a été prise après une
réunion entre les responsables du port
du havvre et les représentants de
l'armateur norvégien un membre du du
commandement du port a admis que les
autorités portuaires se trouvaient
devant un fait accompli d'une part
l'écluse étant bloqué d'autre part les
remorqueurs n'acceptant pas d'assurer le
service du Nord nous avons donc tout
bonnement demandé au navir norvégien
annoncé ce responsable de reprendre son
amarrage et d'annuler sa sortie prévue
pour aujourd'hui nous ne savons pas
combien de temps la mesure sera
maintenue a-t-il ajouté Philippe gasso
qui a suivi l'évolution de la situation
au Havre depuis avantiier fait le point
minutes
depuis 48h maintenant le principal
intérêt des AVR peut être résumé en
trois mots partira partira pas et chaque
jour chaqueur renforce l'trange suspense
l'armateur indique que les premières
haussières qui retiennent le francequet
tomberont à 3h du matin les syndicat des
remorqueurs répondent 1 heure plus tard
il est hors de question de commencer le
travail plutôt qu'à l'coutumé soit 9h du
matin alors on prévoit de débuter la
manœuvre à 9h et l'on attend qu
remorqueurs à 10h un seul bateau est est
à l'encre près de France depuis la
veille les autres ne viennent pas un peu
plus tard un porte-parole des services
du port communique il n'y aura pas de
remorquage tant que l'écluse François 1
sera occupé et d'ajouter qu'il n'y aura
pas de travail non plus si l'écluse est
protégé par la police en fin de matinée
les Ploton de police rest à distance
abandonne la place et voilà où nous en
sommes en ce moment c'est pas un peu un
combat d'arrièregarde pour le panage on
mène pas des combats pour le panage che
d'arrièregarde on se bat pour sauver un
million d'or de travail les port
ourd'h
lesistr pour laèreis le France plusré
leent et mauvais temps personne voulait
manquer un moment que l'avenir
conserverait en mémoire comme l'exemple
unique d'un ambassadeur extraordinaire
passant au service de
l'étranger
noré
pas pour CIT la glire à de la France TR
chur du travil chur du travil le temps
mis subitement au diapason des
circonstances donner le temps à la
manifestation de la CGT qui ne défendait
plus cette fois le bateau mais le
million d'heures de travail perdu pour
les chantiers du Havre les
revendications sous forme de slogan
réclamaient des cales et des bateaux
ainsi que la transformation du France au
Havre qui serait du chômage en moins
mais le cœur n'y était
plus la population non directement con
sembl lointaine comme si le sort du
France était déjà du passé vendu au
Norvégien et laissé au bons soins de la
jvance allemande pour le rjeunissement
pourtant on murmure au Arre que si
l'Allemagne a gagné la bataille
commerciale c'était en un combat très
singulier nous sommes persuadés que les
Allemands ont été mis dans le coup bien
avant
nous cel disons que c une déduction
parce que nous savons que les services
techniques de l'armateur sont assez
réduits et donc il fallait qu'il prenne
conseil
d'un d'un réparateur or ils ont déjà
travaillé avec ce chantier pour la
remise en état de certains de leurs
bateaux qui naviguent actuellement dans
les carabes une pratique commerciale
discutable ah c'est une pratique
commerciale discutable nous étions
devant devant le le fait accompli et
nous avions 15 jours pour répondre on
laisse entendre que les réparateurs ont
pousser un ouf de soulagement quand ils
ont su que c'était les Allemands qui
allaient voir le B fa n pas on veut
faire dire à l'opinion
leousuraéème de log exmile mais nous
étions prêt à y faire
[Musique]
face sur l'écluse François 1 dernier
verrou du France avant le Grand Large
les syndicalistes CGT soucieux de clore
avec Panach une action menée depuis 4
ans s'apprêtent à y passer leur seconde
nuit au Sara occidental on est au bord
d'un conflit armé gén les dirigeants du
Polissario sont en Libye où il
demanderaiit une aide militaire
supplémentaire au colonel khadfi de son
côté la presse maroaine affirme que
l'armée algérienne est présente en
Mauritanie pour s'opposer à l'avance des
unités marocaines dans la région que
Raba vient d'annexer c'est-à-dire celle
de TER gar l'armée marocaine a reconnu
qu'une centaine de ses soldats avaient
trouvé la mort dans l'attaque avan-ier
hier de la garnison de
biranzaran attaque menée par le fr mais
pour bien montrer que les
és blanche et bleu les 350 représentant
des tribus du Tib la région du Sahara
évacué par la Mauritanie et annexé par
le Maroc ils sont venus renouveler le
allégeance au trône devant le roi Hassan
et le prince
héritierant L en bleu le cadi le maire
de Darla la capitale du Sahara
mauritanien annexé par le Maroc il
explique au roi que les habitants de la
région ont décidé de lui renouveler
cette allégance que leurs ancêtres ont
toujours prêté au
[Musique]
sultan à chacun de ces représentants des
tribus du tirisrbi Hassan 2 a remis
symboliquement un fusil mitrailleur M16
américain pour défendre a-t-il dit la
40e province du royaume shériffin qui
vient de naître ou plutôt de renaître
aux yeux des Marocains car aujourd'hui
Araba c'est l'empire d'autrefois que
l'on
[Musique]
reconstitue mais l'éclat de cette
cérémonie s'est trouvé terni par la
défaite qu'a subi l'armée marocaine dans
la garnison de biranzaran attaque où le
Maroc a pu constater qu'en 2 ans le
front pocario s'était équipé d'un
armement sophistiqué encore jamais vu
dans cette guerre du
désert le ministre des Affaires
étrangères des États-Unis monie sus van
vient de blâmer publiquement monsieur
Yang ambassadeur des États-Unis auprès
de l'ONU à New York celui-ci a commis ce
que l'on appelle une gave diplomatique
il a d'abord rencontré tout récemment en
privé monsieur TER représentant de l'OLP
l'Organisation de Libération de la
Palestine à l'enu afin de discuter de
l'ajournement des travaux du Conseil de
sécurité sur les droits des Palestiniens
puis monsieur Yang a donné diverses
versions différentes l'une de l'autre de
cette rencontre l'incident a pour
résultat de rendre encore plus vive
latention actuelle dans les relations
entre Israël et Washington et le premier
vice-ministre vice-Premier ministre
d'Israël a pris l'avion aujourd'hui avec
8 jours d'avance pour se rendre aux
États-Unis et selon les dernières
dépêches de cet après-midi l'ambassadeur
Yang serait bientôt démissionnaire ou
démissionner le pape Jean-Paul II s'est
accordé une journée de détente à
l'occasion du 15 août et il est allé
passer ce jour de la Sainte Marie dans
sa résidence d'été à castelondolpo le
souverain pontif a célébré la messe de
l'assomtion dans l'église par
paroissiale après le petit dééjeuner
pris avec le curé l'évêque d'Albano et
rentrant chez lui à pied il a rencontré
des étudiants de sa bonne ville de
cracovi et les ayant rencontré il les a
invité dans sa résidence pour chanter
avec lui de vieux refrain des
Montagnards de
Pologne à l'occas de l'Angelus le Pape a
souhaité que son prochain voyage en
Irlande et aux États-Unis représente un
pas en avant sur la voie de la charité
de la justice et de la
paix on précise à Rome que le discours
que Jean-Paul II prononcera sur la paix
le désarmement et le développement
devant l'Assemblée des Nations Unies à
New York aura l'importance et la
longueur d'une encyclique c'est ce que
l'on dit aujourd'hui dans l'entourage du
saint l'Assomption à lourde 60000
fidèles l'Assomption en Chine deux
messes ont été célébrées dans la
cathédrale de l'Immaculée Conception à
Pékin seule église catholique ouverte
làb Monsieur Madame giscardestin ont
assisté à la messe en plinaire dans
l'arrière pays d'hier dans le Var puis
le président de la République s'est
entretenu avec le maire socialiste de la
ville monsieur Biancotto qui lui a fait
part de ses inquiétudes devant le
prochain classement du site de l'île de
porortroll samedi le chef de l'État
recevragançon monsieur député maire de
Toulon et Monsieur Léotard député maire
de saint-raaphaël pour évoquer les
problèmes du département du
[Musique]
les incendies de fort des journées si
affreuses monsieur Roger le C doyen des
juges d'instruction du tribunal de Paris
a convoqué pour le 24 at Monsieur
François mitteran c'est l'affaire de
radio ripost on précise de sources
judiciaire qu'il est probable que
Monsieur mitterran sera inculpé
d'infraction à la législation sur les
télécommunications le Parti socialiste
par la voix de Monsieur delelfo secréire
national a réagi aujourd'hui par un
communiqué assez vif qui avait reçu
l'aval du premier secrétaire ce texte
reproche une fois de plus au président
de la République je cite incapable
d'assumer devant le pays la faillite de
sa politique de faire du Parti
socialiste et particulièrement de son
chef sa cible privilégiée et le
communiqué poursuit comment ne pas voir
dans la rapidité de la procédure une
tentative d'intimidation qui vise au
seuil de cette rentrée difficile au-delà
du PS l'ensemble des forces populaires
et il conclut estimant que c'est la
liberté syndicale et politique qui est
en cause par un appel à l'union de la
gauche pour enrayer dit-il attend
l'escalade vers un régime
autoritaire il y a de plus en plus de
Français qui vont passer leurs vacances
aux États-Unis la semaine dernière
Denise Boer s'y était rendue elle aussi
de New York elle nous avait envoyé de
nombreux conseils et montré comment
circuler économiquement aux États-Unis
soit en voiture acheté pour quelques
semaines soit en autocard puis elle a
rencontré en Louisiane un couple de
Français qui était parti bien
étourdiment sans préparer as leur voyage
d'où pas mal d'avatars cette fois-ci
elle a rencontré à Miami et à la
nouvelle-orléand deux couples de
touristes parfaitement heureux de leur
vacances aux
États-Unis il y a à peine 50 ans Miami
était encore un ravissant village de
pêcheurs puis cette ville du sud de la
Floride à l'été éternel est devenue la
terre d'élection des milliardaires
américains qui vous vous en doutez n'ont
pas moins de 70 ans alors à coup de
dollar ont poussé les buildings sont nés
les résidences équipé
au multipl piscin et c'est miam nous
avons rencontréabeth et François de
jeunes Français qui rêvaient depuis
longtemps de connaître la Floride
surtout le soleil allé dans le Nord New
York tout ça on profite pas l'été
vraiment de la plage de la voil et puis
on a toujours entendu parler beaucoup de
Miami et j'avais vraiment envie d'y
aller sont très sympathiques au premier
abord sont très ouverts mais c'est un
petit peu superficiel ça t toujours un
petit peu autour des mêmes choses bon il
parl de de leur maison de leur vie tout
ça de l'argent on parle beaucoup
d'argent ici au éats-unis ça c'est une
chose qui est différ de la France par
toujours de l'argent c'est très courant
que l'Américain sorte son son chquier ou
son carnet et qui mon ses cartes de
crédit moi j'en ai si je me suis bien
débrouillé dans la vie ça va voil ça
très
courant
[Musique]
secondes le début de vos vacances sur le
plan des distractions ça s'est bien
passé très très bien beaucoup d'ambiance
beaucoup de sorties beaucoup de boîtes
de lit non c'est une ambiance différente
je trouve qu'ils savent pas s'amuser
comme on peut s'amuser en France avoir
des bandes de copains alors normalement
dans les films on voit toujours la bonne
bande américaine dans les campus mais en
réalité c'est pas vrai ils sont très
très indépendant c'est pas la bande
comme en
[Musique]
France puis ce fut la découverte de la
Louisiane notre guide Joseph ordogne est
un cagin si vous préférez un acadien son
orgueil fut de nous faire connaître les
Baillou un mot indien qui veut dire
petit t les Baillou sont des marais
immenses qui baignent le
30ou vre
bateau Monsieur et Madame montenet
passaient donc leurs vacances en
Louisianne à la recherche d'un je ne sa
quoi bien de chez nous car je vous le
rappelle la Louisiane nous avait
appartenu un siècle lorsque Napoléon eu
la fcheuse idée de la céder aux
États-Unis moi je trouve que ça m'a bien
replangé dans l'ambiance du livre que
j'ai lu la Louisiane de Maurice
denénusière qui parle des Baillou qui
parle de cette végétation tropicale
enfin de ce mystère de
cette de cette atmosphère assez curieuse
bien que ça certains côtés qui rassemble
un peu à la France le Maré pois en
particulier mais enfin c'est c'est
quelque chose de très très beau
et c'est le contact avec les louisianais
on a vraiment l'impression d'être dans
un autre monde alors le côté américain
extrêmement
or a une chaleur Hume uneitité une joie
de vivre il y a des champs que nous
avons Chan son
[Musique]
plais
sen les
mais pass dans un décor de rêve et comme
au cinéma de jeunes Scarlett viennent
accueillir les
[Musique]
touristes
30 second avez-vous trouvé une empreinte
française à la louisian personnellement
en particulier dans cette cuisine parce
que je retrouve des quantités de moule
et d'ustensil des écumois qui sont très
proches de ceux qu'on rrouve en France
je pensais trouver beaucoup plus de gens
parlant français parce que on vient en
louisian on pense que l'empreinte
française est restée un peu plus et à
part les rues les noms des rues qui sont
en
français il y a plus tellement de de
choses qui nous rappellent cette
emprinte Française un peu dommage
aujourd'hui la Louisiane c'est le
pétrole les champs de coton ont laissé
la place au soja et Scarlett a disparu
la nouvelle-orléand est devenue une
espèce de Pigal où jouent encore les
instruments des quelques derniers grands
du jazz ici comme ailleurs le tourisme
et le dollar sont en train de tuer la
Louisiane des livres d'images 20h je vi
faire une erreur je vous parlais de
Monsieur Léotard qui avec Monsieur X
sera reçu par le Chef de l'État à
Brégançon samedi monsieur leotard est
maire de frchus 22 nous revenons à la
voile mais heureusement d'une manière
calme la 18e étape du Tour de France
Marseille Bandol pas de vent mais un
problème sur la Côte d'Azur
l'embouteillage des ports en cette
semaine du 15 août par les bateaux de
plaisance 16e étape du Tour de France à
la Voile Marseille bando toujours 25
voiliers au rendez-vous mais un absent
de marque levent le régional de l'étape
Marseille arrivera tout de même à
trouver le souffle nécessaire pour se
porter en tête sur la ligne de départ la
méditerran ané à ses humeurs un jour
c'est le coup de vent le lendemain calme
plat les 25 équipages la prendront à
leur dépens sur ce parcours quand le
vent vous pousse à la vitesse
faramineuse de 2 kmh et que le courant
vous fait reculer à près de 2 km/ he
vous n'avancez
pas à ce petit jeu 15 équipages sur 25
bateaux baisseront les bras et
termineront les tapape au moteur entre
autres tous les bateaux de Méditerranée
exceptter la grande mote cette série
d'abandon entraînera un bouleversement
en classement général Brest conserve la
première place devant dunkererque la
grande mote et Marseille qui rétrograde
à la 4e
place 25 voiliers arrivant dans un port
méditerranéen cela pose toujours des
problèmes de place le développement des
loisirs nautiques a été fondé sur le
mode un bateau un propriétaire une place
à qu mais aujourd'hui les ports des
côtes françaises sont arrivé à
saturation par les plaisenciers
maintenant on est envahi on est dépassé
et on ne fait rien pour nous d'accord
enc ils sont en vacances mais il faut
penser quand même que nous nous
travaillons il on fait rien il nous
emballent les filets nous déchir les
filets ils regardent rien n cale dessus
voyez ce matin av un palangre un
plenciel est venu la calé un palangre
dessus nous alors après vous avez tous
les ameçons tout ça c'est tout embouillé
dans les filets il faut couper d'un côté
couper de l'autre et tout actuellement
l'on compte 107000 bateaux immatriculés
pour 122000 places en France le décalage
entre l'offre et la demande explique la
surenchère des prix ici B il fallait
payer 20000 francs il y a 4 ans pour
obtenir une place pour un bateau de 9 m
en 79 le même postequet vaut 100000
franc et le problème semble sans issue
le parc français des bateaux de
plaisance augmente chaque année
d'environ 10 % il la solution de tirer
les bateaux qui navigu pas surtout en
hiver à terre de le remettre à la
demande du propriétaire au moment où va
s'en
servir il y a aussi quand même des je
pense un peu de discipline pour le
plaisancier qui impérativement doit
signaler le moment l'époque à laquelle
il quitte le port son port d'attache de
façon à que le maître de port ou
l'officier de port puisse disposer cette
place carrangera certainement certains
problèmes donc signaler son départ n'est
pas uniquement une une question de de
sécurité c'est très important mais aussi
une question de passe dans les ports en
été il y a quand même beaucoup de
bateaux qui sont de minutes etoup Bau r
bateau rentr peuvent trs bien occuper
les plac deux qui sont dehors au même
moment un problème qui conditionnera
l'avenir des industries nautiques
françaises car actuellement tous les
sites disponibles ont été exploités il
n'est plus question d'aménager des ports
artificiels de type Marina par souci
d'épargner la côte enfin les ports sont
des investissements qui coûtent cher et
finalement qui rapportent peu aux
communes du
littoral grand handicap de la Manche ti
cet après-midi prier le 5 monsieur le 13
cavot 3è le 14 casachmir prince 5 13 14
dans l'ordre pour 5 francs
1242950 sans ordre
2317 la météo pour demain le temps
restera lourd et orageux des pérénées
orientales aux régions méditerranéennes
aux Alpes et au nordest les plus
orageuses parfois abondantes se
déplaceront vers l'est et atteindront la
Corse en soirée sur le reste du pays le
temps brumeux le matin sera nuageux avec
des éclaircis mais aussi des averses ce
soir et le ciel couvrira près de
l'Atlantique nouvelle pluie ainsi qu'un
renforcement des vents au début de la
nuit les températures d'urn varieront
peu mais les minimums seront en baisse
c'est HERV Claude qui vous présentera
les dernières informations demain
antenne demidi vous sera présenté par
Daniel bilalien si vous le souhaitez
nous nous retrouverons à 20h mais j'ai
encore un reportage à vous présenter si
la nature sauvage vous intéresse en
effet si vous savez nager honnêtement il
n'y a pas besoin d'être un champion si
vous disposez de de jours pour sortir de
vos paysages ordinaires si vous disposez
aussi d'une combinaison pour vous
protéger du froid d'une paire de palme
d'un masque d'un tubaat d'un sac
gonflable qui fasse un bon sac de
couchage d'un peu de nourriture aussi il
faut pas se laisser abattre de quelques
vêtements et d'un appareil de photo
voici une idée de weekend ou de milieu
de semaine qui vous séduira je pense la
descente de l'Ardèche sur 30 km de Port
d'Arc à Saint-Martin d'Ardèche à notre
époque où la pollution gagne du terrain
voici les lieux où vous pourrez y
échapper sur les images de lu
comaire bonsoir
merci tout au long de la rivière rien
qu'avec les noms des lieux dit on
pourrait écrire un
poème de
l'aiguille fenêtre les grottes du
Colombier les rapides de l'olivier de la
dent noire de l'irondelle de la canelle
20h 28es 10
[Musique]
secondes 22 28es 20
second 20h 2 minutes 30
[Musique]
secondes 20h 28 4
second parler
superflu c'est la rivière qui sur les
cailloux écrit le
commentaire sur la droite tout suite
après les le bouquet d'arbre qu'il a
là-bas
la
[Applaudissements]
première là
ah oh là
là
voilà ah c'est
bon
allez allez bien allez bien
non
[Applaudissements]
c'est 20h 29es 40
secondes au 4e top il sera
exactement 20h
20h 30 minutes 10
secondes 20h 30 minutes 20
secondes